so I want to explain some things about
uh B okay so she's pushing cuz she has
to have the spinal
displacement right so I'm going to yield
and she's going to hit the ground here
see I'm trying not to go like
this just yield
any number of ways it doesn't matter you
can do your hand this way but she HS she
hits that you see the shape's not
important I just like this extra
yield then
secondarily there's a yield right here
you see there's not a push turn into it
meing because for Ura she had to be
pushing right so there has to be a
yield yield right there and again don't
confuse it with stepping back it's not a
matter of stepping back I can step in
but
it's so
feel
that okay
whatever you're going to feel for that
soft you see it just disappears first it
was
projecting dead go
dead
okay so
uh tell me to just change that W I'll do
it
again do it
again and this
what LO
nope punch me in the face oh with the
grip with the other hand punch me in the
face push me in the
face watch it again without this
punch uh head butt me
head butt me just what you're doing head
butt
me head but
me can you see that so I'm
not he can't come in can't this energy
is going up to this body you see
when it comes in is when I'm around the
back you see that so I didn't I didn't
do the regular Keyon you
see cuz his hand was there so I checked
his hand
already
[Music]
watch this shoulder
now now watch
your so mark his shoulder in space from
the
ground
up or down up an in or
two watch your shoulder in
space down okay because that's the angle
of
cancellation right there you see this is
taking him out of check that you just
put him
in
BO
leave them in
check so here here's my point when it
looks like it's Ikea cuz you're like you
feel that
resistance so you're going to musle it
and then start to take it off like
that but you can only muscle what you're
going y against her y That's how you
muscle it okay so as I I go when you if
you if that was the projection line you
see and I keep lifting up on that line
that makes your shoulder rise ever so
much do you see that did you feel that
it's ever so much ever so much and what
I want to do is after the projection
line I yield here you see it goes
down that's why you want this softness
long H soft it goes immediately into the
cross lateral check on the shoulder
down
down you see that difference okay so you
can't muscle her cuz then you're going
to push the shoulder up you're going to
lose your check okay so you go
soft to
make the shoulder go down
okay which is in conjunction with yin
and yangong you can't
enter pushing on her that's a Yong
conflict you have to yield okay
[Music]
go
Leah lower it lifting the hand is
tension in your hand don't lift it
release come
back release
[Music]
better release no don't lift his hand
you're going to need muscle to lift his
hand release better and you don't have
to do isido ten con to do it you can
also
eat better you can finish the technique
all fluid go no
feetness
[Music]
fluid so more on this Yin Yin
release
he lands right there right on the front
of your rib cage it's on
releas release
B right there elbow in front of your
spine
St right there you
see
not or three or four or
seven one move right there so that's
where we
landed right okay and he'll tap when he
doesn't want anymore you
see it's already on
okay so we're trying to do versions that
you have to Yin in release you get it
that's what we're trying to do okay so
uh and here I'm exaggerating this
because I want you to learn how to go
from uh the Y to nothing you see
immediately off because the the fear the
ego tripartite can almost understand
that but it can't St understand shutting
off do you get it so your here and
it goes right dead right out not when
she stops right after I project it it
goes dead do you see okay so you guys
are going I do slow on on on on on
you're already going that way you see
I'm still on right it's going to go pop
off do you see that got it so here we go
we're going to do that same
skill move off you see
okay now do you see how she's coming
this way why cuz I'm not there to push
her so she's coming this way so I yield
there it is you see and now don't pull
her go around it you see what are you
doing I was ping I know but what are you
doing now watch I'm falling you're
falling right there's my knee boom
there's the
lock okay so
boom pop disappear
you see and watch this if you have it
what do you think that is
Ron what is it deadhesion you see so you
get a little extra but this arm goes
here where it's not doing anything you
want to go like this right instead it's
just here and you're moving out of the
way moving out of the way moving out of
the way she's falling I'm staying up
with her B there she
is so
boom boom off there she fell right to
this arm see here she goes when she
falls her hand came up on its
own i k her hand
down
down you see
p got it that's what you're trying to do
you're not trying to do katak you're
trying to do katak a particular way
okay like it even KN it right here no no
look at the bend on your arm and the
hook on your wrist Ronin you go it's two
inward spirals two inward spirals boom
inward spiral inward
spiral you got to resist the temptation
to grab it inward spiral inward spiral
right onto the
knee you don't need to hook it CU you're
not going to pull it inward spiral
inward spiral right into the
knee one
more over it over it and right into the
knee pop okay see if you can tighten
that up cuz you're taking like 4 in more
of a fur into the technique